WHAT IS RAMPANT FRAUD TO
SURROUNDING MAIL IN INVALID
SPORTS IGNORED BY THE MEDIA MOB.
FIRST WE TURN TO THE HARRIS AND
BIDEN CAMPAIGN AS THE EVER WEAK
AND FRAIL FORGETFUL JOEL CALLS
IT.
DIVIDE AND SPENT MOST OF THE DAY
IN HIS BASEMENT BUNKER PREPARING
FOR HIS BIG DRIVE-UP TOWN HALL
WHERE HE HAS NOT ASKED A SINGLE
TOUGH QUESTION.
HIS RUNNING MATE ACTUALLY HIT
THE ROAD.
SENATOR HARRIS JUST BURST OUT
LAUGHING WHEN DISCUSSING
CHILDREN RETURNING TO SCHOOL.
I DON’T KNOW WHY THIS IS FUNNY,
MAYBE YOU CAN FIGURE IT OUT.
>> ONE OF THE BIGGEST DILEMMAS
FOR ANY OF US AS A PARENT IS
WHAT TO DO ABOUT OUR KIDS IN
SCHOOL.
K-12, COLLEGE, ALL OF THAT.
AND WE ALL WANT THEM TO GO BACK
TO SCHOOL.
[LAUGHTER]
RIGHT?
BUT SAFELY.
>> Tucker:>> Sean: WHO WILL PLAY
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE"?
I GUESS JIM CARREY IS PLAYING
BIDEN.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT’S SO FUNNY,
KIDS RETURNING TO SCHOOL TO GET
AN EDUCATION THAT THEY REALLY
CAN’T GET IN BIG CITIES,
ALLOWING PARENTS TO QUIT BACK TO
WORK, I DON’T SEE WHAT’S FUNNY.
MAYBE YOU DON’T UNDERSTAND WHAT
IT’S LIKE TO BE ON LOCK DOWN
WITH KIDS UNABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL
AND PARENTS UNABLE TO GO TO WORK
AND DEMOCRATS OF WITHHOLDING
FUNDING AND PLAYING POLITICS
WITH RELIEF MONEY.
MAYBE YOU CAN RELATE, MAYBE YOU
ARE JUST FAKE OUT OF TOUCH FAR
LEFT SWAMP POLITICIAN WHO WILL
DO AND SAY ANYTHING FOR POWER.
AFTER ALL WHILE SENATOR HARRIS
REPORTED RESTRICTIVE LOCKDOWNS
FOR MOST AMERICANS, WE THE
PEOPLE SIMULTANEOUSLY APPLAUDED
THE RISING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND AT THE DEFUNDING OF THE
L.A.P.D.
GREAT MOVE, MAYOR GARCETTI,
150 MILLION THERE.
WE JUST HAD AN ATTEMPTED
ASSASSINATION OF TWO POLICE
OFFICERS OUT IN LOS ANGELES,
INCOMPETENT.
IN FACT SHE EVEN PROMOTED THAT
VEIL FUND USED TO GET RIOTERS
OUT OF JAIL.
NO ONE HAS ASKED HER THAT
QUESTION, LETS A VERY SAME FUND
THAT KAMALA HARRIS PROMOTED.
BAILED OUT A WOMAN ACCUSED OF
SHOOTING A POLICE, AN ALLEGED
MURDERER, TWICE CONVICTED AND A
36-YEAR-OLD MAN ACCUSED OF
RAPING AN 8-YEAR-OLD LITTLE
GIRL.
THAT’S THE BAIL FUNDS FUND THAT
KAMALA HARRIS REPORTEDLY
SUPPORTED AND PROMOTED.
NOBODY IN THE MOB HASN’T
BOTHERED TO ASK IT AND THAT’S
THE THE FUN OF THE CAMPAIGN
STAFFERS PERSONALLY DONATED TO.
WILL ANYONE IN THE MOB IN THE
MEDIA, STATE RUN TV, WILL THEY
EVER ASK JOE WORK, LACKED ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THESE THINGS?
THAT DIDN’T COME UP ONCE
TONIGHT.
FROM THE TIME THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRAVEL BAN IN
EFFECT, NOT ONCE.
NOT A SINGLE TIME DID THEY EVER
ASK, WHY WERE YOU CALLING IT
XENOPHOBIA, HYSTERICAL
XENOPHOBIA AND FEARMONGERING
THROUGH ALMOST THE END OF MARCH?
WHAT DID YOU DO, JOE?
HOW IS IT, VACCINES ARE ON THE
HORIZON.
ANYWAY ON TUESDAY JOE GOT OFF
HIS PRIVATE JET IN FLORIDA AND
ANSWERED AS USUAL ZERO QUESTIONS
AND APPEARED TO WAVE AT A CROWD.
THERE WAS NOBODY THERE, IT’S
LIKE A CORNFIELD OR SOMETHING.
TODAY, JOE BIDEN IS HOLDING THIS
VIRTUAL EVENT FROM THE COMFORT
OF HIS OWN HOME WHERE AS PER
USUAL JOE BIDEN BECAME
INCREDIBLYCONFUSED.>> JOE, THIS
FEW MINUTES I WILL SEE YOU
TODAY.
SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE A
COUPLE OF WORDS?
>> AM I SUPPOSED TO SPEAK NOW
FOR -- I DON’T KNOW, I DON’T
WANT TO GET IN TROUBLE HERE.
IT’S ME, OKAY.
WELL, JILL, IT’S GREAT TO SEE
YOU AT A DISTANCE.
>> Sean: MOVE UP, MOVE UP
PLEASE.
JOE BIDEN WANTS TO BE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
THE HARDEST JOB IN THE WORLD.
IT CAN’T EVEN GET THROUGH A ZOOM
CALL FROM HIS SULFITE IN HIS OWN
BASEMENT BUNKER WITHOUT LOOKING
LIKE A TOTAL.
HE ALSO LISTED EVERYTHING HE
WOULD DO IF HE WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT, AND EVERY SINGLE
THING HE LISTED IT, DONALD TRUMP
DID A LONG TIME AGO.
BY THE WAY LOOK AT THIS HEADLINE
IN TODAY’S USA TODAY.
FISA REPORTS POTENTIAL COVID-19
VACCINE AFTER EXPANDING THE
FINAL STAGE THREE TRIAL 244,000
PEOPLE.
WITHOUT LEARNING AND TELLING US
THE VACCINES OPTIMAL DOSE HAS
BEEN DISCOVERED TO CREATE
ANTIBODIES AND MEDIUM MINOR
MUSCLE PLANE.
IN THE FIRST QUARANTINE IN 50
YEARS, WHY DIDN’T HE MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS?
BY THE WAY, I’D LIKE TO ASK IT
IS TOWN HALL TONIGHT, ANDERSON
COOPER.
BUT YOU LIKE TO CLAIM YOUR SUPER
JOURNALIST, AND HE SAID THE BAN
WAS HYSTERICAL, XENOPHOBIA AND
FEARMONGERING FROM THE TIME WE
END UP LAMENTED.
THAT ONE DECISION SAVED HUNDREDS